what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the 10 lives of wolverine
as always if you guys want to keep up
make sure you check the playlist down in
the description we have all the videos
that we've done in order there's only
five of them so far so it should be easy
to keep track then again once we're done
with all this we'll just combine them
all into a full story right so 10 lives
of wolverine 10 deaths of wolverine
because they are essentially two
different stories even though marvel's
sort of releasing them uh bi-weekly
maybe they rap together in the end i'm
not 100 sure but the important thing
here is that this story initially opens
up with a bit of a discussion by
wolverine in terms of like the curse of
longevity it's something to understand
about wolverine and we've talked about
this before wolverine is not an external
for those of you guys who don't know
what that means in marvel comics you
have different types of mutants you have
proto-mutants like gabriel shepherd who
are really really really really powerful
and then you have external mutants and
you just have like regular immunes
external mutants are mutants who are
legitimately immortal they're not
indestructible you can cut off the head
of an external mutant and that would
basically kill them off right so long as
their head is not reattached to their
body they'll basically stay dead but
they can never die of old age they can
never die of disease or illness or
sickness or anything like that right so
they are legitimately immortal in that
way so long as you don't physically
destroy their body they'll live until
the earth is destroyed and if they ever
find a way off the planet in some kind
of a ship they'll live until the end of
the universe wolverine is not that
wolverine's just a person with a healing
factor there is an actual time frame for
wolverine so there was a what if story
that was written and i can't remember
exactly which one it was but basically
it gave us this idea that wolverine
lived about a thousand years and that
was with adamantium bonded to his
skeleton if he didn't have adamantium
bonded to a skeleton we could just kind
of estimate and say maybe he lives for 5
000 years or something along those lines
but the thing about this is that
wolverine has this conversation where he
talks about the idea of longevity right
he talks about what it means to be by
all standards of measurement essentially
immortal wolverine's only been around
for a couple hundred years so if we were
to take that one thousand year period
right we divide it into quarters and we
say 250 years is the equivalent of you
or i being 25 years old that's basically
where wolverine resides in terms of his
overall longevity with all the time that
he's spent he's only about 25 percent of
the way through his life but what he
talks about here is that the reality is
being that old and having been made a
weapon over the course of his life and
different things like that that the
fighting never ends and seemingly
there's always someone after wolverine
now there have been instances where
marvel's wrote his character in such a
way to where he tries to quote unquote
retire or at least what passes for
retirement when it comes to wolverine
but in the end someone always comes
after him whatever the case happens to
be right they want to kidnap him
brainwash him use him as a weapon
there's always someone after him and so
the reality is that his life is marked
by conflict and fighting that's all it
ever really is and he can't really find
any moment of peace but occasionally he
does and when he talks about this idea
of longevity he says what makes the
average person's life so valuable what
makes it so worth living is the fact
that it's so short that the average
person assuming they've lived any
measure of like a healthy life will make
it to about 90 years old right usually
about 80 something i think is the
average not going to swear by that but
best case scenario they make it to their
90s but there comes a point when your
life basically starts experiencing
diminished returns once you hit like 80
you can only go so many places you can
only do so many things you can only
engage in so many activities unless
you're like supremely healthy your life
starts to experience a kind of drop off
i would argue it probably even starts
when you're in your 70s right 60s it's
really when you hit about the peak right
and then at that point it starts going
downhill at a drastic pace right at like
a fever pitch for 60 years you've been
on your way up and in the span of 30
it's wow you know it starts going down
and so it's one of those things where
he's like the people that we fall in
love with the friends that we make the
kids we have right the lives we live the
trips we take things like that it
happens in such a precious short amount
of time and it's a really interesting
thing because he's like that's the value
of what it means to live now the reality
is he's kind of making this whole
discussion in relation to like i always
have to fight for stuff right like i've
got to fight all the time
this is just the nature of me i have to
fight everyone all the time because like
that's his life but it's one of those
things right he just kind of talks about
how he does not like the idea of being
old like that and so what this does is
it kind of switches over now this story
is going to sort of jump around a little
bit but i will do it in such a way to
where it makes it you know easier to
follow but you basically pick up in this
uh the the scenario back in in the year
1900 with uh basically xavier what looks
like his grandfather and essentially
them just kind of being stuck in the ice
now as we know that because the desire
of omega red is to kill xavier that he's
actually launching multiple strikes
through the time stream all seemingly at
the same time and so while there is an
attempt to take out xavier himself at
different points in time specifically in
like colombia then what you also have is
a mega red going back in time to take
out like professor xavier's father or
grandfather right prevent him from
coming into coming into existence and
that that wolverine's mind being sent
back into the bodies of his younger self
at different points in time is designed
to basically save charles xavier and
that's why this version of wolverine
that you get is a lot younger right he's
basically relatively new to his powers
he's about four years out from his
powers and everything really first
manifesting and then in turn of course
he's able to face off against these
forces of omega red and so while that's
happening the grandfather of xavier is
able to actually hold his own right like
literally using like harpoons and all
kinds of stuff just like taking out all
these people that omega red is
possessing and while wolverine's on his
way there we end up finding out omega
red can possess not simply just people
but animals as well the dude seizes
control of a sperm whale and breaks
through the ice now obviously it's
designed to be like an allegory to moby
dick i mean look it's it's the white
sperm whale right you know the white
whale there she blows you know that kind
of a thing but it's kind of a nut
situation because it's just like oh mega
red is basically pulling out all the
stops in order to take out the
grandfather of xavier now the other part
of this is we switch over to post world
war ii japan with itsu now again we
brought this up in the previous video
what kind of rehash it here that itsu
was at one point the love interests of
wolverine and the only woman that he had
ever really and truly fallen in love
with but was also the mother of dakin
now before this whole fight kicked off
wolverine was sharing an intimate moment
with itu of course he told jean grey
mind your own damn business right
because jean grey and xavier are the
ones who sent his mind into the past so
they're basically watching him so he's
like give me some privacy right like
shut off your mind give me some privacy
you know me and etsu we gonna do the
damn thing
and so of course where where isu is
basically possessed by omega red and
then starts attacking wolverine this is
one of the things to know that omega
red's attempts to kill xavier are not
the only thing he's trying to do the
other part of this is to basically stop
the guy who's trying to stop him
now going after wolverine the reality is
any time before the 1960s and team x
going into like uh the the weapons plus
program writes a weapon x when he had
the adamantium bought it to a skeleton
that's the best possible chance to do it
because at this point in his life all he
had was just like bone claws and just no
adamantium and like a healing factor
that's it right he was pretty easy to
kill relatively speaking to the
difficulty of killing wolverine in the
modern era cutting through adamantium is
no small thing in fact the only real way
to kill wolverine in this day and age is
to use a carbonadium sword right to
basically shut off his healing factor
incinerate his physical body and then
keep him in stasis right at least that's
one of the things marvel's kind of been
ambiguous about it in terms of how much
he can heal from and different things
like that it changes all the time it's
ridiculously inconsistent but of course
he basically hits up gene gray and
xavier and he's like i need your help
and so what you end up getting here this
is a really really cool thing that in
the midst of this whole fight between
omega red you know basically possessing
itsu and wolverine suddenly romulus
arrives now here's the thing this is
what's so interesting about this is that
i've kind of been saying what it looks
like marvel's doing is they're writing
the story for the purpose of going back
and basically changing aspects of
wolverine's past this is not one of
those things they change so one thing to
understand for those of you guys who
don't know who romulus is romulus was
created by daniel way and really by
marvel in an era when they were trying
to rework the history of wolverine it's
one of those things i was never really a
huge fan of it felt unnecessary not even
in the sense that i'm just kind of like
his old school origin was the best
romulus is just weird right it was just
a weird story arc and so the way this
worked and it really kind of circles
back to the original origin of weapons
plus and all that which even then didn't
make a whole lot of sense uh basically
you had a guy named john sublime who was
created by grant morrison the nature of
john sublime is he was designed to
represent like intolerance and all that
kind of stuff but john sublime had the
ability to basically possess people but
when mutants first popped up john
sublime realized he couldn't possess
mutants and so sublime ended up
basically developing weapons plus which
secretly started with captain america
and then once he was believed to have
been dead weapons plus started creating
other projects right so weapon one was
captain america that was in the old
grant morrison's new x-men run and then
after his supposed death you get weapons
2 all the way through 10 or weapon x
which led to wolverine what ended up
happening with the whole idea of romulus
is you basically ended up realizing or
at least learning that wolverine's in
almost entire life had essentially been
manipulated from behind the scenes by
romulus right so like the whole idea of
weapons plus and all that kind of stuff
that was all romulus bonding adamantium
to his skeleton that was romulus right
it was just this vendetta that romulus
had against him specifically the death
of itsu and then essentially dakin being
taken that was done by romulus and so
what it looks like is as much as it
sucks marvel's keeping the whole romulus
thing which is stupid but it also brings
in this interesting thing because the
fight between romulus and wolverine is
such that there's the big concern here
right right now itsu is currently
pregnant and this is one of the big
concerns is if itsu dies at the hands of
romulus or with itsu being possessed by
by omega red if wolverine kills her what
will happen to dakin now under the
traditional sense if the mother dies the
unborn child dies right the two kind of
go hand in hand unless that child is so
close to the ability to be born that the
the mother can be rushed to a hospital a
c-section can be performed and the baby
can be safe right but i mean they're
literally out in the middle of nowhere
in world war ii japan the likelihood of
that happening is slim to none
and so that's kind of the big concern
now the idea and what's so interesting
about this is that there could
potentially be a way to basically save
the quote-unquote consciousness of dakin
and basically ensure his survival but
there's no real way to know for sure the
way this timeline originally played out
is that romulus showed up basically
killed itsu snatched up wolverine and
left wolverine if i recall correctly
wasn't even there at the time that it
happened but he's currently here now and
so ultimately what ended up happening is
that back on krakowa sage who is
basically a mutant whose mind works like
a computer had basically calculated all
this and figured like all this was going
to happen because of the mission that
they were engaging in right you know
countering or at least dealing with the
various variables of going back in time
and potentially making changes to the
timeline itself now the results of this
is that in order to ensure that daikin
can survive the timeline can remain
intact and all the things that have
happened over the course of wolverine's
life just by virtue of they can existing
right so like basically everything in
dark rain and all that kind of stuff
that those things can be preserved they
basically have to find a way to
safeguard his existence which sage
basically did she created a system
whereby that could happen which is
interesting because at that point you do
have wolverine asking the question like
you know jean grey xavier is there a way
to make this work they didn't know that
sage did this right so seemingly they're
going to find out that sage did it and
of course deacon's going to continue to
exist but the thing about this is that
that's why romulus is here his presence
is interesting and so of course with
this fight kind of going on between the
two of them then ultimately you end up
having uh wolverine who basically
injures romulus and romulus leaves just
like it originally happened but at the
same time itsu apparently ends up
surviving right she's just kind of
injured but she's not killed this is a
change to the wolverine timeline in fact
jean gray says like wolverine we have to
go it's time for you to leave we have to
go do our thing and so he's kind of like
okay so he ultimately ends up leaving
now whether or not romulus comes back
kills itsu takes naked and leaves keeps
the timeline intact or if e2 continues
to live on is anybody's guess we don't
really know what's going to happen here
but this is a massive shift in the the
timeline of wolverine because the
reality is wolverine didn't know he had
naked he didn't know he had a son that
it was killed dakin was taken and
wolverine had no clue that he existed he
found out later on but seemingly at this
moment right now with itsu basically
surviving she could contact wolverine at
a future point in time and basically
tell him what's happening now the other
reason why itsu survives here is that
with that fight taking place between uh
wolverine and romulus it basically
allowed omega red a chance to escape and
to basically let that fight serve as a
distraction that if wolverine's fighting
romulus wolverine's not focusing on
omega red so mega red can basically
continue his mission and the very least
buy himself a little bit of time he can
be like two or three steps ahead of
wolverine as opposed to wolverine being
hot on his heels now the other part of
this is we switch over to mikhail
rasputin basically with omega red and
again this kind of happens as part of
the lead-up to why omega red's even
going into the past in the first place
again we're getting these little pieces
here we don't know exactly why it is
omega red went into the past we simply
just know that he did and even now we're
not necessarily given an absolute
explanation here all we really know is
that omega red basically got his hands
or at least mikael got his hands on the
cerebro sword which is basically a
system that allows a person who is
essentially plugged into it i.e stabbed
that it allows them to basically hijack
cerebral signal and then in turn use
cerebro to ride the timeline if they
choose to right to send their
consciousness into the time stream more
or less and so again where you really
kind of get this explanation from
michael rasputin that it's a chance for
omega red to rewrite his past we don't
really know what that has to do with
like the death of charles xavier that
seemingly it may very well be like a
favor that mikhail rasputin is asking
for i can give you the the ability to
rewrite your past but you need to kill
xavier for me in order for for me to
basically honor my end of the deal which
omega red is certainly capable of doing
as you continue on here what you end up
doing is picking up in colombia of
course where basically xavier is giving
a kind of press conference here and that
wolverine who's currently possessing his
1960s self and it basically deviated
from his mission with like sabertooth
and maverick and those guys where you
end up basically having him essentially
get to the location of where xavier's
supposed to be and it's kind of like
okay uh omega red should be here where
is omega red you end up finding out that
arkady got smart and that's one of the
things to really focus on here is that
by and large over the years in marvel
comics omega red i wouldn't say has been
depicted as an idiot but he's been
depicted as a guy who's not necessarily
the sharpest tool in the shed the
reality is that that omega red he's he's
the whole like department x red room kgb
the guy's wildly capable marvel just
never really plays up his intelligence
or his tactical awareness in a way that
they possibly could what he ends up
figuring out here is that if wolverine
is the one that's constantly on the
trail basically trying to uh trying to
stop him from killing xavier then why
not just take over wolverine and that's
exactly what he does that when they get
to the scene where like like xavier's
there and jean grey is kind of okay like
i don't sense omega red here anywhere
that's when wolverine chimes in is like
i'm the one they're supposed to be
afraid of that essentially omega red has
possessed wolverine and now has the best
opportunity he'll ever have to
essentially kill charles xavier with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace